uh i see it as as several people have
mentioned is
practice for uh dealing with
a much tougher problem which is climate
change and
uh a one that has a different time scale
and this is where long now comes in
uh where now after this
and it it will sort out it'll take a lot
longer to sort out than people think but
some aspects are already sorting out
faster than people expected
as this thing sorts out and and people
arise and say well that was weird
and terrible and we lost so and so and
so and so and so and so on do we grieve
um but it looks like we're coming
through it
uh humans in a sense caused it
by you know making it so that bat
viruses could get into humans more
easily
uh and then connecting in a way that the
virus could get to everybody
but also humans were able to solve it
well
all of that is almost perfectly mapped
onto
climate change only with a different
time scale in a sense everybody is
causing it by
running being part of a civilization
running a much higher metabolic rate
using that much more energy driven by
fossil fuels which then screwed up the
atmosphere enough to screw up the
climate enough
to where it became a global problem
caused by
basically global activity of everybody
and it's going to engage global
solutions
um probably in light of what jeff west
was saying it'll be you know
innovators and cities communicating with
other innovators in other cities who
will come up with
the needed set of solutions to
emerge and get economy back on its legs
much later than people want but
nevertheless get it back and um
and then we'll say okay what do you got
next
because they'll now be this point of
reference and it'll be like
if we can put a man on the moon we
should be able to blah blah blah
well if we can solve coronavirus
and stop a plague that was that affected
everybody
we should be able to do the same damn
thing for climate